هل الاخطاء التحكيميه جزء من متعه كره
القدم
اخط
اء هي جزء من متعه كره القدم تمام الاخطاء
التحكيميه
ضروري لازم قصدي يتفرجوا على الاخطاء لا
قصدي حلاوه كره القدم بالاخطاء بدون اخطاء
صعبه
تكون اقل عشان عشان ممكن كان في احتماليه
هولندا تتاهل عن همم الارجنتين سؤال ثاني
او بتكبر انتم مع التحكيم والتقريات
الحديثه والبرمجه
والطريق القديمه اللي كان الحكم هو يقرر
في المباراه الحكم
حكم هو جزء من اللاعبين فهو طبيعي هو عايش
جو المباراه هو اللي يقرر لازم نوظف
التكنولوجيا في في تطوير كره القدم شلون
نوظفها مثل اللي حاصل الان في كاس العالم
2022 شلون نشوف التفاصيل الاوف سايد يعني
يعني يبين لك الاكسيد خلال الاقل من سنتي
يبين لك هل هو متسلل ولا غير متسلل هذا
جزء بالنسبه لي يعني يعيد الحق لاصحابه